déjà battus de leur goût ils avaient
rien à voir là dedans mais il a
réagi lui jeannot mula défend son ami
booba respect il est fidèle gerani de
manière ils attaquent courageux et
gilles verdez côté 60
du père des secousses devrait pouvoir
nous emmènera voici l ai déjà dit alors
mais c'est le vrai de lormont mais ça
c'est le vrai ce tocard servi
je perds eaux se calment c'est pas le
vrai de la renommée qui hésite alors je
comprends maintenant ils devraient venir
il a prétexté qu'il a de la fièvre le
lâche oui parce qu'il n'osait pas
l'affronter je l'attends franchement
faire ça c'est bien sûr la fsu non mais
c'est vrai que vos sujets revenons sur
des jets allemagne pouvoir je me couche
devant qui franchement c'est ridicule
sur le sujet des ridicules et faire ce
qu'il fait je trouve que c'est gonflé
quand même
s'ils sont scotchés sinon alors vous
avez vu pupa a répondu à géraldine est
ce qu'on peut mettre toutes les réponses
de booba s'il vous plaît à géraldine
manier c'est affligeant d'être aussi
conne sans masque en plus on voit là il
a repris vous êtes attendus dans les
tranchées pour voir à quoi tu avais pas
vu ainsi géraldine maillet vous êtes
attendus dans les tranchées pour info il
fait 20 degrés le jour le vouloir est
arrivé rhabiller votre premier bout
soldats qui a le lien pour pécho sa
veste ikea idéal pour les tranchées on
va là fut on va la gagner voilà c'est
chou mais non daniel rigolo c'est ton
mari allait aller géraldine on arrête de
sucer ses pieds on y va photo ap c'est
très souple du rallye
et voilà cette infusion d'être aussi
code sans masque en plus alors géraldine
varin répond bien entendu
jg mais qu'est ce que gilles cesser
qu'est ce qui se passe tout aller au
bout de ta vie je suis scotché par
l'autre là j'attends qu'ils reviennent
ici ça va demander sans rigoler mais sa
femme elle par trois mois avec un autre
mec est pas scotché loti nu leurs
attitudes et comment foule record
[Applaudissements]
alors rejoint revois tes priorités
excuse moi en toi tu es pris en juin
2006 simplement bravo booba est la
chercher elle l'a trouvée et quant on
est le genre d'homme elle a été elle
était dur avec lui aussi introduit avec
nous après géraldine un refus jamais le
combat mais on que voilà vingt messieurs
plein on met de l'argent mais je ne te
décides ils répondent après géraldine
sait se défendre a pas besoin d'un
avocat celle-là traité nobel retoucheur
et le combat j'ai dit ça c'est sûr voilà
l'a traité de collabo il a répondu à
virage et la musique collabos à la buba
je trouve que c'est très bien c'est
bienveillance et drôle fantastique mais
laissez moi finir non mais les dames
après booba voile a fait ce qu'il a vécu
c'est ses collabos mégarde un collabo
moi même ça m'a choqué je trouve que la
géraldine a dépassé les bornes et lui ne
dépasse pas c'est tout à son honneur
c'est au père géraldine giraud un
très bon choix quand vous avez peut-être
sous nom alors d'abord moi j'ai vu un
autre un autre poste oui dis que j'ai
dit qu'on est en guerre et que c'était
ridicule et que c'était une insulte à
l'armée alors je continue à dire que oui
on est en guerre on
va mal et le conscient la all in some
pong et ça ce qui peut pas dire qu'on
est en guerre donc on n'a pas d'états
d'âme au front mais en guerre une guerre
économique ya une guerre ne manquait une
guerre énergétique
hélas rien vinea ambiance hier on en
voit malgré tout des armes de défense à
l'ukraine et à des soldats qui sont en
pologne en roumanie dans les pays bas at
il ya nos sous marins on dit pas qu'on
est en guerre mais malgré tout il ya
quelque chose qui est quand même que
l'on une guerre pas une guerre avec
offrons vous bien sûr mais c'est quand
même une guerre